Publica Dominicana. Hay una empresa pionera en este servicio, cargo express corporation entregando de puerta a puerta, cajas, dinero, paquetes, mudanzas y
electrodomésticos que cargo express corporation confianza y seriedad en el
servicio de cargas a la República Dominicana estimados gratis llave para
que recojan su carga en su casa al 978-691-5409 y la línea gratis, 1 800-337-0434, cargo express
corporation 48 de la calle Franklin en Lawrence y en Whistler en el 687 de la calle Maine.
Recuerde que lo importante no es el precio sino el servicio y el mejor servicio lo tiene
cargo Express Corporation. La pionera. La pionera, cargo Express Corporation.
Para la reparación general de tu vehículo debes ponerlo en manos de mecánicos profesionales porque
tu carro merece el mejor cuidado eso sólo lo encuentras en un lugar el adiós auto repair
mecánica en general alineación y balanceo la reparación completa del muffler comas nuevas
y muchos servicios más. El Adios Auto Reaper, 25 de la Calle West & Lawrence, el maestro
Eladio es el mecánico de los clásicos y el rey del moffler. El Adios Auto Reaper,
25 de la Calla West & Lawrence. Y escucha bien si vas para la República Dominicana
y necesitas un vehículo rentado llama a Eladios Auto Reaper 978 397 5502 978 397
el mecanico de los clásicos es
el maestro Eladio y su super
taller, 25 de la Kanye West en
Lawrence.
Cedarview Health & Rehab ofrece
el mejor cuidado de salud en un
ambiente cálido y familiar cuando
necesite cuidado postoperatorio
de corto o de largo plazo.
Cedarview Health &
Rehab ofrece la diferencia
terapias 7 días a la semana
la última tecnología y técnicas de rehabilitación para acelerar su recuperación. Tienen un programa
especializado en enfermedades de los riñones, también programa de rehabilitación pulmonar.
Son certificados de excelencia en cuidados de heridas. En Cedarview Health Every Hub tendrás
servicios religiosos en español, comida hispana e información en español para tu conveniencia.
para solicitar más información
978-943-3774
es Cedarview Health and Rehab
Esto es un llamado a los
americanos que regresan a su
tierra y a los turistas
que nos visitan.
Globo Rent-A-Car
quiere recibirte como te lo
mereces, bien montado
Globo Rent-A Car
con carros de 35 dólares en
adelante
pequeños, medianos
y jefetas
para que te muevas seguro.
Global Rentacar llama a Tony directo desde los Estados Unidos,
617-347-735 o desde la República Dominicana,
809-498-7634.
Global Rentacar, conserviciosa a todos los aeropuertos.
Búscalos en internet como Global Rentacar
y saliendo del aeropuerto sibao a mano izquierda
ahí está Global Rentacar, yo te lo recomiendo
escuchar bien para sus trámites de bienes países o sea compra o venta de propiedad debe buscar la
persona correcta que tenga la experiencia necesaria para que usted se sienta confiado en el negocio
les recomiendo a Lenin Roa. Hola soy Lenin Roa y te quiero invitar a que sigas escuchando los
clásicos con Richie Herrera, Los Sábados por La Mega Lenin Roa me puedes contactar al 646 369
de la calle Probo en Lorenz con
el teléfono 9 7 8 2 0 8 74
40 estamos laborando aquí para
ti desde las 12 de la tarde hasta
la 1 de la madrugada llama
para el Iberia el 9 7 8 2 0
8 70 y 49 para tu venta o
compra de bienes raíces o
venta o compra de negocios los
clásicos con Richie Herrera
tranquilo papá hola qué tal
yo soy más peré de más que
el tixotropical en el 3
24 de la calle Probo En
de los que están en la
ciudad.
Si quieres recoger tu comida,
tienes que llamar por adelantado
y solamente dejamos pasar una
persona a la ventana.
Masterpixel tropical,
978-208-7440.
Quédate en casa.
Teneón auto reaper
en towing,
cambio de aceite
y filtro, gomas nuevas usadas
El aire acondicionado de tu vehículo pasa por el 47 de la calle Windtrap en South Lawrence
es de León, autoriper y towin.
Heavenly Donuts en la Essex
Una mejor forma para tomar café
Ya no tienes que ir lejos porque ahora están el 256 de la calle Essex
Heavenly Donuts
Café
Tea
Donuts
Cosines
Sandwiches
Muffins
Y mucho más
dos cincuenta y seis de la calle es
excenlores ahí está
remodelado a pensiones de
primera en inglés y en español
el mejor lugar para tomarte el
mejor café
en los veinticinco de la calle
excenlores hay un lugar único
en su clase
donde podrás tener la mejor
experiencia en masajes
corporales
en las manos de la experta y
profesional no me perez masajes
de relajación difícil terapias
de puntos para mujeres embarazadas
masajes prenatal, masajes con
piedras calientes y para las
mujeres que ya se han hecho
cirugía estética o liposucción
también tienen los masajes del
grenaje linfático. No me pieres
testera en Aroma Spa.
zapatos, chaquetas y chacabanas, sé tú el artista y diste de tenoche, la que pauta
la moda al vestir. La primera. Además de noche es la única tienda
que te fría cualquier teléfono iPhone o Galaxy sin importar tu crédito y con un
mínimo de inicial de hasta 10 dólares. Y págalo como puedas y cuando quiera
regala un celular sin complicarte la vida ven a denoche donde está mi hielo el presidente de
la ss de noche 49 es estri 9 7 8 9 6 5 25 0 0 escúchame que te gusta verte y sentirte bien ahora
tienes un lugar para la limpieza facial los masajes y la depilación corporal ese lugar
es Marta's Asterix Center, 268 South Broadway en South Lawrence.
No dudas en llamar para una cita, 478-876-7288.
El servicio de Marta's Asteric Center
es eficaz, rápido y seguro.
Todos los tratamientos se realizan con presupuestos
personalizados.
Marta's Asterics Center, 268 South
Broadway en South Lawrence llama para una cita 978-876-7288.
[REVISAR] En el próximo show, Marta,
[REVISAR] estérit center.
[REVISAR] Clásicos
[REVISAR] Eso. Buenas tardes saludos.
[REVISAR] Hola. Aquí estamos en clasico de fin de semana. Buenas
que están el sábado viviendo la experiencia de escuchar
El espectáculo de la radio en todo Nueva Inglaterra
hasta ahora, a través del 95 1 FM y 1400 AM
se produce Clásicos de Fin de Semana
Apaguen las otras emisoras que ya no hay para nadie
Clásicos de Fin De Semana esta primera hora
se le entregamos a usted, vio? Te escuchó
A los típicos gracias a Heavy Littonets, Pancho Coffey
2.26 de la calle de Sextran Lawrence
y ahora en adelante vamos a disfrutar del mejor tiempo de la salsa del merengue
del bolero, de la bachata porque por ahí anda ya
es el fin de semana
eso sí pero también anda morenaje que está por aquí
ya anda en las instalaciones de mega
el morenaje que viene a continuación
de los clásicos con su bachatón
bueno no sé el toque le queda
no se como a la baña
qué bueno
comunicación conmigo a través del 987 10 8344
además el ocho cinco cinco nueve cuatro nueve noventa y cinco diez esta tarde me voy a dar un
banquete yo mismo me lo permiten digo me lo permiten si verás que sí ok porque hoy el especial
de las cinco vengo en boleros vaya buscando su compañía tílica preferida a las cinco
la tarde vengo con el especial de los boleros pero en estas dos horas antes de las cinco son
las tres y quince, verdad que sí. Vamos a disfrutar de un repertorio riquísimo. ¿Te
sabe por qué? Porque le vamos a averiguar el conocimiento musical expresado en la música
del merengue y la salsa del maestro Sonny Ovalle
tocándote casi coste fin de semana
usted no se imagina la cantidad los temas que ha reglado sony el maestro sonio
valle ese señor te veía tocando piano con wilfrido vargas hay un señor calvo
vera que así con su migotazo ahí tocando piano
¿Usted nos imagina lo que ha hecho por el merengue y la salsa en la República Dominicana?
Pero se lo vamos a decir aquí, los clásicos, sí, para eso estamos, ¿verdad que sí?
Vamos a disfrutar gracias a la gente que ya está conmigo a través de YouTube.
Clásicos de fin de semana te activa la campanita
Y ahí le vamos a salir cuando estemos en vivo
Hágase socio también del canal
Deje que el mundo goce
de les share, de les like, bien y entonces vamos a disfrutar esta tarde de lo que ha hecho
el sí Sonio Valle, el maestro Sonio Valle por el merengue y la salsa de la República
Dominicana. Ya veo por ahí el Majinbe del Fuerte, le dicen que es lo que es Richie está
en YouTube. Hola Majinbe, hágalo usted también a ver quién anda por ahí. El maestro
Sonio Valles según escuché su historia llega a la capital y en ese tiempo pues viene de
Salcedo provincia hermanas Mirabal se ubica en la capital pero te sabe que en ese
tiempo las cosas eran difíciles y llega y comienza a tocar en los bares, en los
restaurantes, en los lugares de la vida alegre de la capital hasta que lo
que se llama Johnny Ventura, Johnny Ventura, sí señor, con Johnny pasa un tiempo hasta
que llega a la orquesta de Wilfrid Vargas pero eso lo vamos a ir contando poco a poco aquí.
Espera que sí.
Trocándote clásicos de fin de semana.
Vamos a empezar a disfrutar de este repertoriaso que ha hecho con sus arreglos el maestro
Sony.
¡Allá! ¡Vamos arriba!
Haciendo historia en la radio de Nueva Inglaterra
Radio de Nueva es desajado
En el corazón del Sibao
Él es Richie R.A.
De los clásicos
Escuche este primer tema
¡Hey!